on the gate spot stage on day two of III
I'm your host camp robinson and it's a
pleasure to have actually with me how
you doing a suit yeah great to meet you
so we're going to be talking all about
dark souls to the first piece of DLC for
dark souls 2 crown of the sunken king so
I think we got a trailer so we just go
straight to the trailer yeah let's go
all right let's go straight to the
trailer and it looks just like me
here it is
you
all right lots of underground pyramids
and you bosses and things going on there
so tell me how I was just you because
your street parts 3 dlc parts ok hear my
words are coming there three different
sections of you'll see right ok so tell
me what's the plan with that are the old
based around a search for a different
crime is that how it works yes um so you
know after we actually least the game we
were really surprised about the game
being leased this is so cool imputation
from the both fans and media in the
Western market and so we have decided to
create three TLC's only after we Lisa
maintain oh well CS was the original
flat just like we were really working on
a tight schedule that it was even that
long ago yeah quick turnaround yeah so
um you know so since then you know the
main game itself is already providing a
complete experience so we decided to
provide the additional situations
additional level designs to the players
so we have decided to come up with the 3
DLC so basically sweetie LCS each of the
dlc is featuring a really unique
situations the first dlc the crown of
sunken king is taking place at the you
know the poison luhan's located Lily
Lily on the deeper in the ground and the
second DLC taking place at the you know
the deeper inside of the iron keeping
the main game and the third DLC is
taking place at the you know super court
area covering snow and ice that's the
situation taking place in the hdlc okay
great so tell me more about the car
honking King in particular like who who
is yourself who is the sunken king was
yeah I said okay you know the crown
those three crowns those are used to be
belong to the drawn Greg's Kingdom and
rake in the main game so the players
mission is to basically search Verde you
know that those lost three clowns in the
each of the three of us apart from there
the situations which are obviously
different the environments in your 3 DLC
and what else is going to be unique
they're going to be unique new boss
types in each yeah it is a difficulty
going to be different across all three
shelli relations so the difficulty level
arm typically live over the hdlc will be
relatively higher than those
that is because we're pretty much
considering assuming that the experience
that dark souls 2 players will be able
to access to each DLC that is that as a
matter of fact there's a some certain
conditions that the players need to meet
meet in the game the main game in order
to access to the 3 DLC that is to get
the ashen hurt me a hardcore game and
then at least visit the undead crib that
is say you know the conditions they have
to meet this is a pretty much louder
part of the game so I believe that you
know only experience that players will
be able to access to the 3 DLC and also
not only that but the in addition to the
main loot we will be having a
challenging route in hdl-c I so explain
that a challenging routes okay so so you
can go one way the kind of the standard
way or you can take the really difficult
path is that right yeah it's a difficult
path okay and we're assuming that you
know most of the players will try to
complete this challenging route by a
co-op so there's a interesting uh you
know points that I want to highlight
here that we're expecting although only
a DLC purchaser will be able to access
the most of the part of the hdlc but
there's exception that is the challenge
for our loot for this part we're hoping
that then not only the DLC purchase it
but even non DLC purchaser to be
summoned by do see purchaser in order to
do a code that is a lily I believe this
is a very interesting you know feature
for so if you don't have the DLC
somebody does can summon you into their
game yes exactly that's how it works
that's how does that work in terms of
the content though I mean how will the
person be able to be someone into the
game if they don't have the DLC
installed um basically how it works they
said it depends on the hardware on
hardware but in most cases all dark
souls 2 players will be downloading the
compatibility pack gosh yeah dlc
purchaser will be downloading additional
unlock key to unlock the dlc con the
drug works so basically everybody
playing the Dark Souls 2 2 will have the
same game data yeah so the data is there
it's just you you get
access to basically if you if you buy
the dlc okay thanks let's rest a really
cool idea I'm so with dark souls 1 you
guys did produce DLC you produced one
massive and it was there artorias of the
abyss right now this was a huge piece of
DLC yeah are we should we expect the
crown of the sunken king is of a similar
size or are you doing like three smaller
bits of deals in terms of the game ball
your mom you know for example map name
appearing in the game screen is about
approximately three to five for each dlc
stage okay so it's similar to the
foulest of fallen Giants in the main
game in terms of the game problem okay
when you guys put all three deals in
together the size of the three DLCs will
become about like 1.5 times of the
arterial supply base for the docs want
okay okay under do you purchase the the
DLCs like separately or can you do can
you buy them all you know if I so how
does that work question are we're not
going to be forcing players to download
all three do CS it's up to players the
weather which DLC day I actually
download arm even the turns that we
don't mean I kind of forcing players to
you know arm play DLCs insert insurance
it's up to players ok but but it depends
on the platform but for some platforms
we got to be offering a season pass so
the players can get you know three TLC's
in the discounted price and I really
really recommend to get all free I'm
sure you would recommend that is because
that is because because when player
complete all three DLCs there will be a
big surprises so I want people to
experience this you know big surprise
okay I'm can we actually let's roll that
b roll again as she cuz i wanna ask you
a couple questions just about the
environment yeah looks like you've got
these underground pyramids so where's
the inspiration from from that why did
you want why did you go for these on the
ground and you know the inspiration
coming from the you know having the
situation which was not available in the
main game because you know all 3 dlc oh
yes as you can see this is the you know
the part of the stages are from the you
know first dlc but
you know it takes place in a pyramid
there's something assisting in South
America simulator dosage something
insist in South America so we want to
offer totally different experience that
the people couldn't experience in the
main game by this DLC what are you
fighting here whether were those enemies
oh okie just a little calculator with
but the unique features is that the you
know because of the first dlc not only
the enemies but also the stage itself is
something the player needs to conquer
there will be a lot of you no gimmicks
that the plane is to turn on in order to
you know I'll get to the final
destination so there's a lot of booby
traps and gimmicks please tell me about
this enemy resistor um in regards to the
nomini not not only an enemy but the
items weapons spells everything is brand
new for h toc ok because of that so
we're planning to adjust it you know the
overall game balance when we ladies the
dlc so not only the dlc but we also
going to be leaders in the regulation
file as well as the latest patch file
every time we ladies fiancée in order to
adjust that you know the overall game
balance ok excellent so I mean it's it
is quite soon after the release of the
of the main gaming how did you guys
manage to turn this around so quickly
how long how long have you had to work
on this thing a good question arm unlike
you know that the big deal see the
auditorium service for original Dark
Souls oh we have a issue with you know
the schedule um we want to offer this
DLC as soon as possible to you know the
players so that's why we have party we
have decided to you know create three
separate DLC in that way we can offer
our hdl-c as soon as possible to the
gamers ok so am let's talk a bit about
you mentioned that you mentioned there
is you can a weapons and equipment and
everything can you get can you go into
any specifics like what type of new
stuff well purchasers of deals to be
able to get their hands on I can do that
you know those items weapons that the
enemy or boss enemies are wearing doors
are brand new but so it should be
interested in getting those ok and this
is a game gonna be identical across you
know ps3
my xbox 360 pc is gonna be identical on
all three okay yes same experience yes
okay well m hi i mean i hope you brought
it to e3 or is it is it playable here
can people get their hands on it are you
just showing off the the kind of game
play wow you know ballad uncle games
we're having a you know the business
boost up this error so all the media can
able to access today you know the first
dlc at there are demonstrations Oh
excellent right right and then I mean
III this year has been has been really
quiet has been a huge success I think so
far we've seen some whole lot of new
games we've seen some excellent stuff on
the stage here as well what's I'm just
initially what's up what's the pic of
what you've seen it III this year ah mr.
I haven't had that much of a chance of
visiting you know um other booths at the
show floor but I'm pretty excited seeing
the assassins creed yeah I want to do a
demo yeah you what you well I mean that
there is playable other so aggressive in
trying it on that yeah she stopped by
there I mean it's interesting you
mention assess Creek is I'm it seems
like they can a fantasy genre is alive
like now like it's never been you know
it's the number the number of games you
know third person first person fantasy
you know fighting games are our huge I
mean so is there anything else you watch
once you kind of look at and say well
you know dark souls has got the really
duly challenging kind of market covered
but while their games out there do you
kind of look to for inspiration when
you're when you're creating DLC when
you're when you're working on Dark Souls
while the ones you really look at and
think yes ah well in when it comes to
DLC I think you know the EA is a good
example I mean I know actually
Activision dearly well plan yeah
especially in case of a call of duty
there we'll plan from the beginning
unlike us because that's what we decided
create the studio since only after we
released a waiting game so well it's
really something we want our respective
we want to learn it's great that you're
able to turn that around so quickly
that's awesome well it's been a pleasure
having you on stage thank you so much
for showing your gameplay alright silent
Gordon joy the history three and make
sure you get that Assassin's Creed mo
yeah yeah